I told you this was coming in late 2017
and it is growing as of yesterday there
are 30 senators co-sponsoring a bill to
repeal the repeal of net neutrality or I
guess to reinstate Obama's net
neutrality provisions and those are
provisions that by and large are really
well liked by Americans it's the cable
companies and their lobbyists and big
corporations some big corporations only
who have been advocating for the removal
of those net neutrality provisions
lawmakers have 60 legislative days after
the FCC submits its regulations to
Congress to pass what's called a
congressional review act reversal the
Congressional review act allows Congress
to reverse the decision made by the FCC
if they do it within 60 legislative days
so it's great news that now there are 30
co-sponsors to this repeal of a repeal
of net neutrality in the Senate it means
that now it is going to get a full vote
on the Senate floor but I hate to be the
messenger of bad news it's still going
to fail because this is just Democrats
right the Republicans have the majority
they are not going to be able Democrats
are not going to be able to undo what
Trump's FCC has done even if the
Republican constituents want net
neutrality even if their constituents
will be hurt by Internet service
providers being able to do whatever the
hell they want it doesn't matter because
only Democrats are going to vote for
this and like we've said before this is
a political stunt but it might be the
type of political stunt that has some
utility in the 2018 midterms and in the
2020 election because there will now be
a record of senators who given the
opportunity to restore net neutrality
will have either abstained or voted not
to restore net neutrality that can be
used against them in upcoming campaigns
now there's lots of people in the
audience last time I mentioned this
effort who said David this is a great
thing no matter what and I agree it's
good but it could also be easily
deflated by Republicans who take the
small government approach where they say
listen
president Trump appointed a GPI former
Verizon lawyer
the FCC has made its decision we're not
now going to go against the will of that
body so I I genuinely don't know of what
value it will be in the 2018 and 2020
elections what I do know is any
publicity that can be given to net
neutrality I'm in favor I'm actually a
little bit more hopeful than you are on
really button because I think you take
those 49 Democrats yeah right then you
add in John Thune from South Dakota
Republican who said that he's actually
in favor of some of the net neutrality
provisions and then maybe add in some of
those Republicans who are on their way
out like bob Corker Jeff Flake or McCain
you could get something there I don't
see it has so I just don't see I'm gonna
understand it's not gonna pass the House
president's not gonna sign it absolutely
absolutely so you know the the bottom
line is the FCC is a disgustingly
political organization it's not there
for the benefit of the public it's been
completely co-opted the term regulatory
capture could not apply to any agency
more than it applies to the FCC former
Verizon lawyer Ajit PI appointed by
Trump he now is running the FCC so it's
necessary for the public to activate
against the FCC rather than being able
to count on the FCC to defend your
interests and that is horrible and it's
a good reminder of do not fall for both
sides are the same yeah there are many
issues where there are no no sort of
practical operational meaningful
differences between Republicans and
Democrats one example is the sort of
implicit or tacit support for the status
quo of how politics are funded in the
u.s. that's true Democrats and
Republicans very similar but Democrats
are all going to vote to restore net
neutrality and Republicans are not with
the exception of maybe the couple that
Pat is talking about although I don't I
don't see it happening there are
important differences between
Republicans and Democrats and this is
one of them interestingly on the state
level Nebraska is considering putting
something forward that would protect
some of these net neutrality provisions
I saw that and even though it's
controlled by Republicans it still has a
good chance of passing but I think it's
because there on the state level and
thus much less corrupted than the
federal level that could be done in
other states but we're not yet seeing
any big
hunger for that so it's it's great that
there's thirty co-sponsors sadly it's
not going to pass let's take a break we
will speak to Don Jeffries after the
break
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS